dans l'atelier de reliure de bénédicte
bon ouvrier offert gistoux thé
traditionnel tout est fait à la main et
du coup j'essaie de fournir en matériaux
et matériels les plus traditionnels
comme l'a si c'est une scie à greek et
avec des dents bien particulière avec
une dégaine si un peu particulière donc
ouais tout et tout être additionnées
cet ancien libraire est ouvert son
atelier il y a cinq ans elle s'est
formée auprès d'une artisans rôle hier
car oui c'est souvent comme ça que l'on
apprend cet artisanat rare un métier qui
demande de la patience et de la
précision là je fais l'opération qui
s'appelle la couture
qui est l'opération phare de la reliure
j'utilise un instrument qui s'appelle un
couloir et qui va nous servir de trame
pour maintenir les cahiers les uns avec
les autres
la couture n'est qu'une étape parmi au
minimum une soixantaine d'autres pour
restaurer un livre et cette façon de
coudre à l'ancienne permet de rendre le
livre presque indestructible
actuellement cd dos collé avec de la
colle industrielle
tout le monde en a eu dans sa main même
un livre de poche quand on loupé ça
craque les feuillets se se détache alors
que la livre traditionnel qui a été
relié à la main cousu
il bougera pas donc c'est le gros
avantage
si vous souhaitez découvrir l'art de la
reliure bénédicte bonnouvrier propose
des ateliers hebdomadaires ou des stages
une bonne manière pour les livres de
recettes de grand mère ou les manuscrits
rares de commencer un nouveau chapitre
de leur vie
[Musique]